hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm
Dave Rubin according to the paperwork
I've got fred Karger and brett erlich
with me here we go all right turkey you
may have heard that something's going
down in Turkey although the mainstream
media has kind of dropped the ball on
this if you are a fan of The Young Turks
jank it's doing a nuanced and effective
job of explaining what's going on so I
want to talk about it in a kind of broad
way basically a bunch of protesters were
at gezi Park
the Turkish government was building
another mall they've been building a ton
of malls partly because the economy is
good and people want to shop but there's
no green space in Turkey people want
parks they're not happy this has turned
into riots and protests and all kinds of
stuff but we are not really hearing
about it here in America which is a
little bizarre because we heard about
Egypt we heard about Libya and and
what's going on this is our big ally
Obama called the Turkish Prime Minister
erode on his his best friend in the
Middle East so something is amiss Fred
what's going on in Turkey and why are we
hearing about it that's where I want to
start on this I think there's just it's
a sleeper problem right now and I mean
if I were in Turkey I'd be demonstrating
you can't even get a turkey sandwich in
Turkey go to Greece why I don't know I
looked all over cuz I wanted a photo
when I was there of me eating a turkey
sandwich but it's it's it's what's going
on all over the Middle East right now
and it's a secular government it's a
secular prime minister and there are a
lot of religious factions there and I
think it's a lot of other reasons I
don't think it's necessarily what what
the one issue is for more green space I
think he's got some serious problems and
and we could see another downfall of
another regime yeah so before we get
into the specifics of what's going on
there what do you think of the media
coverage as a media guy it seems very
bizarre to me that we're seeing like 30
seconds on CNN and then you know OJ
Simpson again because it was the Arab
Spring and we got behind everyone who
sprung up at that point and it was very
simple and we just ran the gamut there
was that you know just northern Africa
and we just dealt with and then it got
to Syria and suddenly it was complicated
right and now everyone's looking at it
oh god I'm sure I first of all Syria
involves a lot of homework then I'm just
I know this all the photos of Turkey
look like photos from occupy Los Angeles
but I'm sure if I just peel it back it's
gonna be too messy let's get out of it
yeah I actually think you're totally
right on this that Syria has caused us
because we don't know who the good guys
are there we don't know who the bad guys
are everybody's killing everybody and I
think we sort of have this fatigue we're
having like Arab Spring fatigue where
it's like oh this is just a repeat we
could just watch the footage from you
know from Cairo so what is our
responsibility in the world when this
stuff goes on because there's definitely
like this thing in the United States
right now like we can't get involved in
anything and I'm not saying we should be
involved in Turkey and it's you know
it's not nearly as bad as the other ones
especially Syria but what is our
responsibility when we're broke and
people don't want us all over the world
and all that
well Syria is the problem and that is a
hot spot and they're factions and like
John McCain who want us to go in there
and take sides on the rebel arm the
rebels read the Taliban yeah so we're
we've got a problem in in that area and
of course Israel's gotten in and taken
out some what they believe are some
problem areas that are fueling their
enemies through Iran yeah and when you
look at the map of Syria it's surrounded
by Lebanon and Iraq and Iran were we've
got some serious geographic problems
there we need to watch it carefully but
I don't think we need to get into that
area and expose our troops because of a
civil war that's going on there but
Assad has has got to go yeah is part of
the problem that Syria is such a freakin
mess that we can't do anything in Turkey
because we sort of need the the
government there because that we are
friendly enough with them that we can't
have turkey going down while Syria is
going down I mean it's just dominant
turkeys is a different beast than all
the rest of the Arab Spring nations
because Turkey yeah
Turkey's secular you know it is it is
more than you know 50 person it's mostly
Muslim yeah so it's like this weird you
ever see the movie there the TV show
sliders Jerry O'Connell
you would like or like yes later he
would like slide into a different
dimension where most of the stuff was
the same and there was like one key
difference
that's what turkey is like Moe you look
at it it looks like San Francisco yeah
but like something like with you and it
all has like Roman letters but like then
you see like the little you know Tierra
says those two dots over the over the
little over some leather yeah and you're
just like wait a minute that's not
that's not San Francisco right but I
think what we can glean from it is is to
understand that right now it is it is in
the nascent stages of something that
that could get big but right now it's
pretty much localized to specific parks
in certain cities there's some fantastic
hashtags like resistant ball yeah that's
a good that's something we can glean
right but isn't it funny that it takes a
hashtag to get us involved because
you're sure because truly I mean the
Turkish Prime Minister said this week
that the biggest problem here is Twitter
not has other newer the government but
Twitter is causing unrest you know cause
like when we think about like a nation
somewhere in like a Muslim zone yeah we
think of like well the big decision is
do how much power do we give a dictator
because you know otherwise there's a
bunch of like really crappy factions
that would all kill each other maybe it
needs like someone to be just a jerk
yeah and kind of you know a little bit
bigger of a jerk but like you know
turkeys always on the on the the cusp of
being led into like these really big
awesome clubs that that mostly Western
nations are led into right there in NATO
and they do behave in a mostly
democratic way yeah and yet they're not
fully democratic cuz they're in a pretty
crappy part of the world yeah I was in I
was in Turkey a couple years ago and I
was on a tour cuz I'm a tourist not a
traveler I'm a tourist yes and I would
act finding this was a fact-finding
mission like where is an RVs cuz I'm
tired of your food but no this guy was
like you know we're really close
together being led into the EU except
for like you know the genocide thing
it's a little testy still and he was
like laughing he's like that Turkey
we've got we got problems
yeah what do you
all right final thought on this so the
part that seems fascinating to me is
that we don't it seems very obvious to
me that America doesn't want anything to
do with that part of the world anymore
but if we if we pull out and we have no
money and all that stuff and we don't
want our troops getting killed all
legitimate reasons if we don't do
anything good is there anyone left like
I feel like the world will just go to
hell in a handbasket and maybe that's
just the way it's kind of gonna be
because no one else is gonna jump in and
ever try to try to do something good
right if I mean if the US doesn't do it
is anyone gonna do it well I like what
the Secretary of State John Kerry is
doing right now which is trying to
negotiate with Assad and to get a some
peace there James Baker who was this
Secretary of State under George HW Bush
he went to Syria 23 times to try and get
Assad's father to go to the Madrid peace
talks and that's what we really need
keep going back he was persistent he
finally got Assad on that twenty third
trip to go to Madrid for the peace talks
so we need to negotiate we don't need to
just go in there and arm our arm the
rebels and I think that's a better
solution right we're working on it right
they want armed rebels we don't know who
the rebels are I also saw that this week
now France is saying there absolutely
was chemical weapons in Syria and it's
like well well now what do we do like
why is it that we care more about how
people get killed whether it's by
regular weapons or chemical weapons then
how many because 80,000 seems like yeah
people that's a diplomacy word cloud
because we know that chemical weapons
are a bad thing that sounds bad and we
went in because we were looking for them
in Iraq if we actually find them
something must be major right
yeah and it's me like yeah and right now
in the grand scheme of things like
relations with Turkey are touchy anyway
because recently there was that run-in
with the Israel and Turkey we made
turkey an enemy and we need them because
they're a foothold in that area I would
think of you know this is terrible what
I'm about to say but Syria is in Africa
major and Turkey is in Asia Minor so all
right well anyone on CNN wolf if you
want to air this clip to explain some of
this stuff that seems to have gone over
your head you have full rights to it I'm
happy to lend it to you okay let's move
on to oil the big oil you know we're
talking Middle East so you got to talk
about some oil and let's talk about the
gays because we cannot get a week by
without something happening to the gays
Exxon Mobil shareholders
voted for the 14th consecutive year to
reject a resolution that would have
added non-discrimination protections for
their LGBT employees I mean what really
is that 14 years in a row guys what are
you doing Fred I know this is right in
your wheelhouse you've been an LGBT
activist for a long time you've taken on
exon amongst many other companies where
does this come from how in 2013 with all
the progress are they as a bunch of
stodgy white men that's what I picture
them as sitting in an office and gone no
not gonna you know we're gonna keep
discriminating against the gays one word
Texas they're Texas based you know
largest company and the corporation in
the world kind of goes back and forth
but when they took over mobile which had
a good track record on LGBT rights they
they threw those out and kept their
discrimination and they a human rights
campaign the largest LGBT political
organization rates the top thousand
corporations in the US and from a zero
to one hundred well now they've given
exxon mobil a 25 - I have the negative
zero so yeah I did a commercial I took
on ExxonMobil for a very good reason
when I was actually campaigning about a
year ago not only because of their
bismal civil rights record but because
of their gas pricing and gouging of the
American public which hurt our economy
and we need to get aggressive against
these companies I've been leading a
boycott of Amway because they gave half
a million dollars to take away gay
marriage and states all over the country
I think we need to boycott companies
like Exxon they are nine point eight
billion dollars in the first quarter of
the year an astronomical amount of money
but if we can hit them in the pocketbook
I think we will get them to come around
and do the right thing yeah is money and
boycotting me like what what's going on
here is that the only way we can affect
these guys because they seem to only
care about money right this is is this
about trying I'm trying to do what they
view as the right thing yeah like I can
boycott you know I'll try real hard to
boycott but I don't think everyone's
gonna boycott you know right mobile I
mean the thing you can do you can't say
like don't don't visit Exxon Mobil you
know get I guess you can actually you
can say listen you're at a corner
there's three gas stations
just don't go to that one right but that
go to be because they're all they're
doing all yeah so what do we go we're
gonna try to like check off the ones
that haven't totally screwed people up
yet right she'll I think they're okay
hundred rating at nature's I love it I
love that Berkshire Hathaway beat our
ExxonMobil by scoring zero points right
listen that bonkers it's insane
so what do we do here because right
you're not gonna look us a few couple
people that are for gay rights not going
Exxon all right fine but is this just
like one of these things where
corporations
it's like Walmart dumping you know tons
of stuff into the ocean and then paying
an eighty million dollar fine it means
nothing to them like is this sort of
like we just can't stop these guys we
every one go out there and boycott Exxon
Mobil but I just like thinking about it
in terms of you're voting it's not like
you're not voting for it you're
literally voting against it but if to
say come on it's so fun to discriminate
against gay people yeah that's our one
thing let's let it just let us do it
yeah so what is going on in these
boardrooms when they are voting because
as Brett saying they are literally
sitting there and deciding whether this
is not part of a bigger issue what are
they saying
what are they actually saying like this
is our one little secret they don't care
about their employees and their
customers and it's an insult in 2013 to
do this and it's intolerable and I say
we go after these companies I did for
boycotts during the prop 8 campaign we
ended up settling three of those with
major donors to the other side six
figures and up and so we need to put
pressure on these go across the street
to Chevron prices usually a little
cheaper than Mobil and support our
friends and don't support the enemies of
equality and I'm a firm believer in that
I'm not organizing a boycott against
Exxon Mobil I did a very effective
commercial which got a huge number of
views I call their chairman Rex
Tillerson Tyrannosaurus Rex because he
is living in the dark ages and we need
to get some pressure on these companies
to do the right thing and it's working
these are looking to brag that they have
a hundred on HRC now yeah and I want to
get Exxon Mobil from minus 25 up to a
hundred is part of the problem here that
it's the government because you know we
couldn't
past the employee non-discrimination Act
and not that I want the government
jumping in on everything but if we could
have got that passed then they wouldn't
be allowed to get away with something
yes I mean if you force people to do
this kind of thing then yes they will do
it and I think that there are plenty of
other you know legislative initiatives
that have passed in order to move the
football down the field and try to
advance the cause it's just one of those
things where you look at it and you're
just like I am shocked like who are
these people
yeah what are they doing do they have
they ever met a gay person yeah and I
mean a lot of there a lot of their
defenses you know there are other
portions of our training videos where we
say that people should not discriminate
against gay it's just it is so simple
for you guys to just sit around have
this vote change it and don't tell
anyone and then a year later tell people
that you changed it just do it and then
no one will have any reason to go
complain about you are they on the other
hand just like really vying for that
like anti gay consumer right it's just
like you know listen I have this pump
phallus and I'm putting it into my ionic
tank and I just want to do that yeah you
know well I think you're right that it's
like they never get screwed you know you
mean they're they're used to always
getting what they want and reaping tons
of profits from it so it's like for them
to cave to the gays right about a little
sign would be so catastrophic in their
minds because they run the show when it
comes to public policy and politics
their profits are just astronomical and
we need to keep the pressure on them in
the pocketbook where it hurts and I'm
convinced they will come around like all
these other companies you know Sachs
which has of course a huge number of
LGBT associates that call and certainly
customers of New York and Beverly Hills
in San Francisco they have a zero rating
with the HRC too I think it's important
to get that information out right so
people know don't go to Saks go to
Bloomingdale's that has a ninety or go
to Nordstrom's that has a hundred I'd
much rather support our friends and I
think that's important and there's
there's no company that's too big to to
boycott yeah and I'm pretty sure Saks
has a couple gameplay
you think there might be one or two
there
yeah it's there's no monetary benefit
for them to to have this policy you know
there's only monetary and negative
fallout yeah you know no one I don't
think anyone's flocking to them because
they hate gay people so digestion
hustling Ben's Department exon do it for
the money if nothing else if that's all
you guys can respond to all right let's
let's talk about weed because this show
is best watched while stoned a former
Microsoft executive Jamin Shibley he's
gonna start the first commercial pot
company basically the Starbucks of weed
I think this is a great idea it's
starting to get legalized across the
country of course it's still against
federal law so this is gonna cause all
kinds of problems legally and you know
can you get investors and all that stuff
do you guys see this basically as you
two pot smoking maniacs that I know you
are is this this is just all good like
somebody had to jump into this space and
this will will help the legalization
process and the whole thing yeah he's
giggling like a STONER or until pot is
legalized on a federal level this guy
it's gonna be hilarious to watch this
guy because I know people who are
licensed to grow wheat yeah and they
have the card and they're raided by the
feds and the feds are just like and the
guy shows the card and the feds are like
all right I'm not gonna take you into
custody but I have my quota on how much
pot I need to seize a quarter and I know
I can come to you whenever and they take
it and they steal hundreds of thousands
of dollars of product and so he does not
have any recourse but to just start over
and that is exactly what'll happen to
this guy okay so I this is happening all
over the place actually where I live in
West Hollywood one of the places was
raided a legal place in California and
then you're right they take a certain
amount of the weed about what do they do
with the weed that's what I want to know
they just because if they're burning it
and I want to find out where they're
just smoking the hell
I'm saying right but what was really
what do they do with the weed when they
confiscate drugs what do they do with
the drugs well just sell them back to
Mexico and then they sell them back
cause they incinerate it they incinerate
it they put it in a big thing and they
incinerate it and then they reclaim the
fumes and they don't let anyone smoke it
yeah now Fred I know that I've birds
flying over the top just sending yeah
yeah Fred I know I can't say this too
loudly here but you are a and which
means that I'm guessing you're really
four states right so I assume you see
this as a states rights issue we're in
California the feds should have nothing
to do with this right well I do and I'm
all for marijuana legalization I think
it should be treated like alcohol it
should be controlled taxed there should
be age requirements and we should be
reaping the profits as a you know state
federal local government is opposed to
these medical marijuana shops that are
charging the same price that the street
charges and I think one of the great
things Obama did from the get-go was
when he his Attorney General said they
would not be enforcing federal marijuana
laws in states like California and 15
other states and there are hundreds and
hundreds in LA City they're trying to
limit the number of medical marijuana
distribution stores down to 130 we just
voted on that last month so I'm
encouraged and I think the fact that
this guy is trying to treat it like a
business raised money he's got the
former President of Mexico and a partner
which is interesting Vicente Fox where
they want to bring the right guy went
from behind is in another country
basically to a weed salesman well he's
going up actually they take that money
and they put some money into these other
states like Colorado and Washington that
just legalized marijuana it's just like
gay marriage it's gonna take a number of
states and then the federal government
will change the drug laws and yeah
that's the whole strategy all if you
guys want some numbers on pot and how
profitable is a United Nations report in
2005 said the world wide pot rate was
142 billion that was about eight years
ago I'm guessing it's a little bit more
now
honestly why let's just get let's go to
the philosophic okay this why don't they
want citizens smoking weed what's the
you know you mean like all beyond the
joking stuff like what why no one's
there's always there's over tobacco we
people equate it to alcohol its advice
let's regulate it and have laws against
using it while doing things that can
endanger people such as driving and
everyone has said listen though you can
drive stop oh yeah but you it's hard for
a police officer to verify how close to
the time of being arrested and driving
you were smoking pot because of how long
it stays in the system now they're in
there introducing better ways to judge
that but it's just not quite there yet
and so that's an issue yeah
other than that it's just been illegal
see that's what I think it is it's just
so systemic that no politician wants to
be the guy that's just purely associated
with pot it just makes him seem like
Terry Johnson yeah look I look like I
couldn't get in a debate and you know
was the libertarian nominee as governor
two-term governor of New Mexico he
crusaded for marijuana legalization from
day one so there it is a movement
there's some very wealthy people like
George Soros and Jonathan Lewis that are
out crusading for marijuana legalization
and I think the fear is it's a gateway
drug and to me who started experimenting
with marijuana in college it's much
safer than alcohol and it needs to be
legalized it needs to be regulated and
we can gain a huge amount of tax revenue
from it i but also this is where I give
it it's a gateway drug isn't that just
insane I mean if pot was disappeared
altogether there was no more pot around
tomorrow would suddenly everyone be
smoking crack I don't think that's you
got a smoke something robots around so I
don't have to smoke crack exactly if you
want to get off on something let it be
pot instead of crack being sober is
horrible
hariya is that bad that I would smoke
crack just if there wasn't pot yeah I
advice what I want I don't want to be in
this guy's business I want to have the
like Steak and Shake next door to his
pot businesses so everyone goes in oh I
put together
he's gonna need a name Oh his chain
little research and so I found some
traditional chain restaurants and I did
some plays on them
so instead of Apple B's there will be
Apple bongs maybe it's a good idea
instead of Outback Steakhouse Outback
Bakehouse oh I like that instead of five
guys five guys who are really hungry for
pizza right now not burgers shouldn't
they be hungry for burgers even maybe
burgers and then instead of TGI Fridays
TGI wait what day is it TV these TVs all
right final point on this do you think
that really I've mentioned this before
on the show but like my thing we read is
that the government just doesn't want us
thinking they can't have a populace that
is gonna be thinking about things and if
you smoke a little weed you might start
thinking that this whole thing is just a
bunch of BS and and having some thoughts
that are a little outside the box the
government's not in that business is
that the real problem here I just think
that it's a lot of stodgy people who
have a misconception and as more and
more people there was a this guy running
for I mean or was nominated by Reagan
for the United States Supreme Court well
turned out in 1987 he is admitted
Ginsburg using marijuana well that was
unheard of and of course he had a
dropout well now that is not a
disqualification you've got the last
three presidents at least who have
experimented with marijuana and stronger
drugs and so whether it's reflective of
society it's changing its changing
quickly and I applaud all those leaders
and and funders who are making these
would you ever vote for someone that
said no I've never smoked probably would
I wouldn't you don't put pot as a I
don't think it's like a qualified you
shouldn't be in the cop it's like would
you vote for someone who doesn't drink
and maybe it doesn't matter I mean I
don't trust them as much yeah I mean you
should have a glass of wine at night
it's good for your heart
absolutely all right from from weed to
aliens let's talk about UFOs because UFO
sightings have been going through the
roof especially in Canada I know there's
not a lot going on up there so maybe
there's some connection UFO sightings in
Canada doubled in 2012 1981 sightings
and of course UFOs in case you don't
know what a UFO is it can be a dis
hardly shaped object a large square
triangular brat black craft a ball of
fire or even objects shaped like guitar
picks I don't know which article I got
this room
alright let's in case I wasn't clear on
that let's take a look at some video of
there were 1981 UFO sightings reported
in the country last year about five a
day that's more than twice the number of
reports in 2011 when there was 986 now
the number of cases in 2012 completely
eclipses all previous records for the
highest reports in one year which was
1004 in 2008 right so there's a little
more info on the UFOs in Canada but it
has been happening in the United States
and all over the world as well so first
off guys do you believe in UFOs have you
had an experience with an identified
flying object what I like about the
description of UFOs is like it could be
a ball of fire yeah I'd hate to be the
alien who is assigned to drive the ball
this is just not comfortable the shiny
thing that seems nice the ball the fire
seems like a bit much yeah for sure
Canadians I just like to say that those
things flying in the sky are called
airplanes we've had them down here for a
while just so you know that that's where
they are not a conspiracy theorist Fred
do you believe in UFOs and what do you
make of all these what do you make of
numbers jumping I don't believe in UFOs
although I have seen one and so I don't
believe it buddy what do you mean what
is driving out on the 62 palm springs
very late one night and a UFO flew
overhead but I'm not so sure I didn't
see anything that was suspicious other
than it was disc like bright light in
the sky that didn't look how much more
suspicious would he want it to be
wouldn't feel better if somebody had
landed and come out yeah I just I think
that maybe they did get one alien
landing and Canada about 45 years ago
Celine Dion other than that
I don't I don't really believe it though
yeah you're not the only one who
prepares jokes before I really want the
alien to just land and go yeah I mean it
seems to me we're a tiny little rock
next to a very average star and we're
here so why wouldn't there be other
planets and civilized life out there
uncivilized life doing some stuff do you
think a lot of the reports on this
though are just because we all have
phones and we all the videos and cameras
you know 10 years ago if you saw
something you just go right to the
mental institution now you make a vine
out of it yeah exactly a lot of this is
like there's that car driving and
looking out the window that looked
pretty weather balloon er just balloony
to me so at least now we have like video
of these things in a video itself is
pretty rundown so it's like now we can
not trust a video the same way we didn't
trust some weirdo telling us they saw a
UFO yeah do you think in times when
seems like the world is a little
upside-down and the economy's not great
and there's Wars and all that kind of
stuff but we want to believe in stuff a
little bit more just for just for like
our creative mind to feel like there's
something better than just this thing
that's going on of course movies help at
books help create these ideas we have
images of aliens right now anyway just
thanks to Spielberg and a lot of other
people and so I think it's important and
to keep that imagination and and hope
for additional life as long as they
don't destroy the world like all the
summer movies are showing us yeah but I
I think it's good that people are aware
and you know the conspiracy theorists
abound with this because the all the
things that have happened in this
country that they think are creating
other life but from other planets but I
think it's I just think it's bunk and
this is it solar systems are too far
away I don't know how they get here we
don't think there's any life on any
other planet there's a real you're
debating yourself the answer to how they
get here is warp I don't know if you've
heard of war but they warp here like a
wormhole situation
yeah so that's that's pretty simple
friend now but since you know a lot
about this
what's with the anal probing hey they
just I think they're gonna find there
that you can't find from questioning or
maybe they had one experience where they
did find something and so they just keep
going back to the same source but
there's a theory that the Stephen
Hawking even said which is like listen
if you see an alien don't talk to it
it's probably coming here because it is
depleted every resource on their planet
and they're looking for resources here
and if we were to do the same thing we'd
probably be like I'm sorry primitive
Society but like we really need clean
air at this point right okay so I'm a
big sci-fi guy and almost everything I
believe I learned from Star Wars
do you think there's any chance that if
civilizations were ever to to collide
and meet each other that it wouldn't be
a case of what you're saying where you
know we have to destroy them because we
need their rocks to make oil or you know
an avatar situation is there any chance
that like better humanity or alien and
Amity will will work is there any chance
through this scenario and you want to
know my actual thought on it cuz we had
a better thing that I have gone through
this like dialectic in my head so it has
to be embarrassing but it has to be far
enough along in the development and Co
discovery of alien systems within each
other where they've had those in
experiences and determined that they're
terrible and so the same way that we had
were like there was like the West and
finally in you know moved to the new
world and ruined civilizations and then
the world got smaller and so we start
realized we couldn't just blow each
other up so it has to be far enough
where there's some kind of alien UN and
they find us at that point in their
development assuming there's not some
caveat for like really primitive
societies or it's like no one will
notice that we killed them and also
because our own UN here worked so well
that I think that's a pretty credible
theory and for some reason I believe it
okay I was being sarcastic about the UN
all right let's talk about Hollywood and
China because
China is making a lot of money these
days they pretty much own everything
they probably own this chair and
everything I'm wearing and everything
you are sitting on right now and now
they've sort of infiltrated Hollywood
and everyone's talking about how the big
Hollywood blockbusters especially are
all being funded by China and they are
putting regulations on the movies in
terms of content because they don't want
to offend the Chinese audience because
they want to get into that market China
only allows 34 foreign films to be shown
annually so if you want a piece of that
money like transformers 4 which is
partly being shot in China you're gonna
do things that the Chinese government
wants you to do basically I mean this
again this is sort of like the exon
story we did earlier this seems to me
just about money but how dangerous is it
that something as lofty as our film
business here could be infiltrated by
the Chinese Fred well it's a communist
country and they have a lot of control
how many kids you can have and one-fifth
of the world population with the fastest
growing economy so Hollywood as we do in
this country Scout owing to their
demands and the limited number of films
that they're exposed there but like 10
new screens are opening a day in China
so it's a huge Virginie market for us
and when there's money there's Hollywood
and I think it's good because we're so
limited in the number of films we can
make right now based on funding that if
they will support some of these films
either financially backing them and also
and go into the movies I think it's
great yeah is there an artistic issue
here though because you know there's
already been examples of let's see you
know things that have been produced
co-produced by Chinese companies where
they take out content that maybe the the
bad guy is Chinese and instead they make
them Taiwanese or something like that
you know demean and is there so just do
we have an artistic problem when we're
making films that are gonna be backed by
another one sacred thing about Hollywood
blockbusters in the summer is their
artistic integrity yes I think that yeah
if transformers 8 didn't have a Chinese
villain robots I mean people would just
completely lose it and we would lose
that that in depth
highly honed social commentary that we
find in Michael Bay
explosion films were fighting robots I
could do a three-hour show on
transformers remember the scrotum joke
in the second one where John I was like
I was in I've been in countless like
Coen brother movies we're underneath the
enemy scrotum and literal lines that
being Constructicons that he was get me
started there is something weird about
this to me because you know even the GI
Joe movie that the sequel just came out
a couple months ago
you know GI Joe when we were growing up
was and and when you were younger was
was the real real American hero that's
what he was called GI Joe in the movie
is not a real American hero it's like an
international group of fighters to save
the world you guys don't see any like
odd inherent problem with that that
we're losing some sort of American pride
thing because we're trying to I love it
China is helping our economy immensely
particularly in luxury retail that's
who's buying all this stuff right now
they have their own Facebook Ren Ren and
I guess we bow is their Twitter and we
need to adapt to that the presents can
be meeting with the Chinese premier in
Rancho Mirage this week and I think
that's exciting that we are working
together and we need to take the two
biggest economies and mesh them and
Hollywood is certainly no exception as
long as they don't censor them too much
because I think well we'll lose a lot
but it's important that we work together
with China and get along and hopefully
they'll have a little uprising there and
have a democracy in that country someday
right but how do we stop them from
censoring because they own us first off
and then they're gonna back our films
like how are we gonna stop them hey guys
guys it's just it finds an equilibrium
is what's gonna happen like and the best
part for China is they don't have to
change at all there's definitely like I
cities in China are far more Western
than people would think they are so yes
there's always pressure coming from the
Sidda fide versions of China to to the
government saying let in more
westernized stuff but I mean the people
who will bend over backwards more than
anyone or the Hollywood studios because
all they want is the bottom line so
they're willing they're actually in
cahoots right my concern is that like
how do we find out who
hate other than we up you'll watch the
news and that's just takes so much time
or like that's boring yeah so we need to
find out through movies who we hate and
if China isn't a villain because of this
how do we know we're supposed to hate
them you know I agree with your crazy
point there because I was thinking even
this week with this whole Syria thing
it's it's very clear that Russia is on
the other side you know they're backing
Assad we're backing the rebels and there
is this thing happening and I tweeted
this but we need like a rocky 4 you know
I mean in Rocky four you knew Rocky was
American Drago was Russian at what site
but I feel like we don't have anything
to sort of take our geopolitics and
bring it into mainstream thinking maybe
grateful I spent my youth in air-raid
shelters but the Soviet Union was gonna
blow us off the world so it's good that
the world is getting along we don't need
to be your holes we there's a lot I like
canned tuna a lot of that no it's the
world is is functioning right now and it
is one world it's exciting to see and so
we got have enough enemies out there we
still got Iran we got North Korea and
that's that's plenty all right well from
enemies to happiness our final story
this week a new Harris Poll says that
only one in three Americans say that
they're happy which would explain all
the antidepressant commercials on TV
let's take a look at some numbers
happiness so yeah 33 percent this is the
happiness index as you can see on our
very fancy card 33 percent of Americans
say they're happy happiness levels are
fairly high during youth they get a
little less when you're in your 40s they
increase again in the mid 50 is peaking
later in life probably the minute before
you die
optimism 67% of respondents say that
they were optimistic about the future as
compared to 75% in 2011 so that's
dropping and optimum optimism levels in
the US are significantly below the
global average eighty-nine percent of
citizens internationally feel that the
future will be as good or better than
their present situation so this seems
actually pretty in line with everything
we hear all the time that this
generation of young people is going to
be worse off than their parents for the
first time in America
in history and it's just being so
ingrained in us that America seems dunzo
kind of is America over and are we truly
less happy and have a worse outlook
these are difficult numbers and we must
sift through them first of all the
global average of 89% of people in the
world think that the war of the future
will be as good or better there's like a
billion people who don't have toilets
exactly so how much worse could it get I
think that's just kind of
self-fulfilling that it has to be better
right are they gonna take away my not a
toilet right oh no no we're gonna take
away my whole and we're saying you know
can I get PlayStation 4 so we have a
pretty good also this is people saying
they're very happy and to be honest I
hate those people people like oh it's so
good today isn't it a gift yeah I just
want to smack or shake them yeah so
that's that's my happiness spread how
happy are you on a day-to-day basis how
important is happiness in the in the
fred Karger operation i think it's very
important of course and as a gay
activist has been interesting as i've
talked to a lot of parents particularly
those with LGBT kids and i've asked them
what what do you want your kids for your
kids and the number one thing is to be
happy I think that's so ingrained in us
it's important and put everything else
aside that's kind of the bottom line and
they're varying degrees of happiness and
you can't be this very happy mood all
the time it's a roller coaster so I
think it's good I think the question I
have in the studies of course you've
couldn't depend on how the questions are
asked couldn't be all over the place but
I don't know if people get that much
happier with age I think there's a lot
of depression with older people as
they're left aside in the world but I
think it's good and Brett says this is
important it's all relative what is
considered happy we're so fortunate in
this country to live in this in this
nation when you go around the world and
see everybody lined up at our consulates
who want to come here just fact that
we're in this country with these
freedoms that we don't have in places
like China we're very fortunate just be
happy yeah one of the things that I
thought was fascinating this poll is
that they showed that in Israel they're
much happier than us which seems bizarre
because they're surrounded by enemy is
there a bombs going off all kinds of
other stuff so maybe it's it's our
excess and all of our freedoms that in a
weird way make us not happy is that
possible that we don't have existential
threats so we can be worrying about
nonsensical things all the time yeah
I've been watching The Sopranos again
little AJ has everything and look at me
did we give them too much is what Tony
and and Carmela asked themselves all the
time maybe that is it I just think if
there's also like a complaining culture
on the rise where it's just nice it
makes you feel happy to complain and
then there's a politeness issue where if
you just rub it in people's face how
happy you are
all right the fact that two out of three
people aren't that happy kind of makes
me happy so if we can all take solace in
that maybe the two of the three of us
who were like sad about it and we'll be
happy again and and maybe then we'll all
be happy yeah do you guys think that
maybe happiness is overrated as part of
humanity like no other species on earth
you know they eat and they die and they
kill and you know make babies but we are
constantly under this pressure that we
have to be happy I always think when I
was doing stand-up all the time when I
just started I was really struggling and
I had no money and I was working shitty
gigs doing all this awful stuff people
always used to say to me well as long as
you're happy and I always thought it was
crazy like why should I be happy I'm
trying to follow my dream I'm hanging
out with drug addicts and alcoholics
every night why should I have the burden
of happy happinesses can be a weird bird
in two can it as opposed to just living
some sort of even-keeled slightly
depressed operation wouldn't that be
easier sure it's a lot of work and we
all live that life that's up and down
and that's that's important to realize
but take advantage of the happy times
and and just know that you want to live
a good life be good to other people
that's my measure of happiness when that
you close your eyes for the last time
it's like what kind of life did you live
where you're a good person and so I
think that's that's happiness my
definition
all right so a final thought unhappiness
because like we can't talk about
happiness without talking about the
prescription drug situation because you
turn on the TV and literally every
commercial there's a sad cartoon chasing
a man around all day in another man who
can't get an erection another man who's
bald and they all have horrific side
effects including depression and death
and all that kind of stuff but is this
again because we
put so much pressure on ourselves being
happy that we're taking drugs that are
making a suicidal of us not happy then
we take another drug because now you can
take and vilify which you know works
with the other thing and blahblah
happiness and drugs to deal I think
we've always been kind of depressed I
feel because look at the image and this
is just we now have drugs that can help
us as opposed to like getting on top of
it not just you know there's a fine
there's a line of mental illness and and
in that kind of thing which is like
official and clinical that you know I
don't want to get into but like there's
definitely that fringe where people like
just give me some zoloft or something
but that said the American Dream is come
to this country you'll have freedom
awesome your children will have freedom
great and you just work hard every day
and wait a minute go back to that I have
to work hard and in that is an implied
struggle and I think that explains well
in the middle of your life you're just
pretty sad because you have to work so
hard and hopefully by the end when
you're retired you know that work is
hard then then you get you're free to be
happy but there is a streaming in every
narrative of the American Dream there is
struggle and struggle is not the
happiest time of your life and on that
note I hope we've added a little
happiness to your life this week that's
fred Karger that's brett erlich i'm dave
rubin we do this every week there's like
buttons and subscribe things and all
kinds of other buttons just click on
press them whatever you got to do and
we'll see you next week Thanks